crews are still cleaning up the mess
left behind after yesterday's heavy rain
and strong winds
three micro bursts swept through
southern nevada leaving as many as 17
thousand homes and businesses without
power and the energy says power has been
restored to most
hector mejia is live near boulder
highway in russell where the cleanup
continues this afternoon hector good
afternoon
the crews are still all around this
neighborhood continuing the cleanup as
we were driving around we still saw
snapped trees and neighborhoods and also
take a look at this this is a large
power pole
that came crashing down here on this
residential street
we saw some other damage out here but
this is some of the debris we've been
finding here throughout the day
those appear to be power lines draped
over a truck and
those lines go up on the roof of a home
right now less than a dozen businesses
in this area remain without power
several envy energy crews are out along
northbound boulder highway right now
near russell the company estimates to
fully restore
power by midnight to the 11 businesses
yesterday's powerful storms came with
winds as strong as 60 plus miles an hour
nv energy says it knocked out 17 polls
in this area
that left about 1700 customers without
power yesterday but the majority of that
was restored
by 11 p.m now the shelter set up by the
american red cross at parkdale rec
center is closed for the day
only three people stayed and left once
the lights came back
on earlier today we talked with a man
who described hearing the destructive
winds and
the large power pole here that slammed
to the ground just one house away
heard of just in this rain coming down
and then i stepped out and then i looked
this way and
saw the whole light bulb on the ground
and
it was it was crazy it was like to me
it's like a mini hurricane a mini
thunderstorm it's crazy for about 45
minutes
it was it was wow
a lot of people have been describing the
storm the same way and this is the same
region where
31 power poles were blown down almost
three years ago to date
this is video of that it happened july
2018
near boulder highway and galleria so
back out here
so this storm also came with a punch we
also reached out to the american red
cross
they said if you are not able to stay in
your home because of yesterday's storms
you can still reach out reach out for
help
their number is 1 800 red cross
reporting near boulder highway in
russell hector mejia
8 news now